the victim hierarchy is a pyramid you
can also call it the victim pyramid VH
or VP it's up to you at the base of the
pyramid you have white men that's the
lowest ranking they cannot be victimized
by anyone and yet they victimize
everyone else we have to understand is
that victimization flows up on the
pyramid so it's a little
counterintuitive higher you are on the
pyramid the more victimized you are and
yet the more powerful you are and next
you have white women which and they're
still pretty low on the ranking but they
can at least be victimized by white men
so they have one victim Point victim
points are determined by how many other
groups can victimize you so you can
tally a group's victim points simply by
counting how many groups are underneath
them on the pyramid it makes it very
easy to do